I want to turn right now to a friend of
mine it's been a long time since I've
spoken to him however and I'm pleased to
have here on this show one of the top
evaluators of football talent that's of
anywhere to be found the analyst from
NFL matchup executive producer as well
from NFL Films Greg Cosell how are you
Greg it's great to be with you thanks
great to have you on this show sir is
Joe Bauer number one overall a
no-brainer in your mind because we're
hearing that maybe the Dolphins are
considering trading up to number one
overall we know how unfaded they've been
with two of four a couple of years what
how do you assess that very important
question Greg well I see Joe burrow is
clearly the number one quarterback
prospect so to me he's number one I
think he's a better prospect in Atilla
why I think burrow has better traits
overall into I think that when you look
at borrow the only thing you would say
would burrow you could say the same
thing about tour but I think the only
negative and reasonable people will
disagree about this is that he doesn't
have higher level arm strength but I
think every other quarterback trait that
you're looking for burrow possesses and
he's terrific with his understanding of
pocket movement both inside the pocket
outside the pocket he's very poised he's
very calm I think he has high level
traits other than the arm strength and I
think different people will see that
differently but the NFL passing game has
changed where do you stand on the
subject of burrow Greg that his sample
size is smaller it was just this past
year in which he exploded and you'd like
to see that happen in the NFL not just
in the year right before it what are
your thoughts on that's what I answer it
this way rich I think that almost every
quarterback is a system quarterback
there are very very few exceptions to
that maybe a Patrick mahomes with this
incredibly high level talent but every
quarterback is a system quarterback and
it depends then on the system you're
placed in and what you're asked to do
you could argue drew Brees is a system
quarterback so I think that to me that
that's not necessarily a valid point to
make about a quarterback because there's
very very few guys who are so special
that they transcend and can play in any
given system so where do you put two on
the
in order of the quarterback listening is
he - uh I think - is very much system
based I think he's a timing rhythm
player I think he needs to be in an
offense where the ball comes out quick
where he hits his back foot and he moves
and the ball comes out I don't think
he's a great athlete I think that for -
it to be a great player in this league
stylistically he would have to play like
a Drew Brees he's not Russell Wilson
he's not that athletic
I think his movement ability is fine but
it's not high level so I think he needs
to be with a team that understands what
he is and what he isn't but if you put
him in that situation where rpoS or a
big factor where it's a rhythm passing
game he can be an effective player and
are you aboard the borough as Brady comp
are you aboard that train right I think
his poise and composure and calmness
reminded me of Brady I can he beat Tom
Brady boy you know I tend to talk
stylistically with that kind of stuff
because I'm always leery of comparing
players to guys who are you know Hall of
Famers like Tom Brady or Drew Brees so I
always used the word stylistically he
moves better than Tom Brady Brady was a
great mover within the pocket borough
can move a far better outside the pocket
Greg Cosell here on the Rich Eisen show
so it sounds like you're not very high
on - look Greg I guess but only in
comparison to borrow or what where does
he fall and gets in the hole pecking
order with Herbert and love and and the
rest of the group that were I would say
he's a good prospect I don't think he's
a great prospect I don't think there's
anything about to his game when you
watch him that you say wow I happen to
be a Jordan love fan i like jordan loves
game i like his his overall talent level
I like the fact that he's a ball
distributor that he's also a rhythm
player and he's 6 4 over 220 pounds -
has one issue rich that to me needs to
be cleaned up and he can be cleaned up
he has a tendency and maybe because he
knows he doesn't have a big arm he has a
tendency to do what we call climb the
pocket step up into the pocket when he
doesn't need to and at 6 feet that needs
to be cleaned up because he will create
his own pressure in the NFL if he does
that so do you take her
/ - I would potentially take love / -
and I would take love / Herbert you're
that high in love so are you aboard the
love as Patrick mahomes train no no no
that's I understand that comparison
mahomes is a really special talent right
love is talented and and is he the kind
of quarterback that theoretically has
similar abilities yes but he's not
Patrick mahomes Patrick mahomes is
really a special talent not many people
throw the ball like Patrick Mahone's so
based on what you're saying
Greg Cosell Washington definitely takes
chase young at - after burrow goes one
dissensus you would think well let me
ask you a question this is a question
I've been debating him in my brain where
you know I've had a lot of time to get
into my brain these last two weeks right
what's more important in the NFL these
days an edge pass rusher or a big time
corner I know there have been studies
done and a lot of people debate that
because the nature of NFL passing games
has changed rich to where it's much more
quick games right three-step drops
five-step drops the ball comes out now
obviously when it's third nine it's
different but Jeffery a CUDA to me and
again I'm gonna throw a name out and
people are gonna go oh my god you're
saying this is the way he is but he kind
of reminded me stylistically of Champ
Bailey I really like Jeffery o Cudas
tape well I would take chase young in a
heartbeat I guess to answer your
question Greg you know okay you're not
wrong no and I understand that you know
having that corner because of how
quickly quick how quick how much quicker
the quick game appears to be getting in
the NFL on the offensive side of the
ball just being a Big Ten guy and and I
saw CUDA but it's seeing seemingly hung
man I mean I saw how Penn State try to
handle him and whether it was chipping
him or then not just letting him letting
him loose and then using that
potentially to try and open up a screen
or a quick game that didn't work I mean
Michigan changed their entire offensive
game plan for him to try and erase him
and he was
if you will removed in terms of the stat
sheet but the fact is that they changed
their plan for him that's the type of
guy I would take no and I have no
problem with that I mean he's he's got
high level trait size length high level
athleticism I got to see him in person
at the Maxwell Club dinner in Atlantic
City and he looks the part so no I have
no problem with that he has high level
traits Greg Cosell NFL Films and NFL
matchup analyst here on the Rich Eisen
show where what here's the question that
we were asking at the combine what is
Isaiah Simmons and by that I mean the
position what you draft him and play him
as watts
in the end I feel like I should answer
that with a line from the movie airplane
you know what is uh you know you
remember that of course um I say it
Simmons to me and I'm in the minority
even though he's almost 64 and 238
pounds I think he ultimately plays like
a safety so in a base defense I almost
see him as a big safety I know many see
him as a linebacker but I think he's the
kind of player that you want to get away
from the body's not aligned him where
the bodies are where I think his value
is tremendous in the NFL is in sub
defenses nickel or dime defenses because
that's where you can line him up at
multiple positions and I think in many
ways he's a much much bigger tire and
Matthew in the way he'll be deployed
I think the Derwin James compass is
reasonably valid but Simmons is a great
athlete I don't remember the
interception he made against Ohio State
I guess it was in the national semifinal
game he was retreating as a deep safety
and then showed tremendous range to pick
off Justin feels his game is more like a
safety even though his size says
linebacker Greg after that play I
received texts separate text from two
New York Giants fans saying take him
fourth overall that's what you remember
the play well don't you oh yeah I mean
from two different friends of mine for
Giants fans saying I want him but don't
you think that when when the Giants are
on the clock gentlemen goes a protector
for for Daniel Jones and if he does who
who does he take I think that's one of
the most in
reading spots in this draft because
Simmons is a special special athlete
right there's not many Isaiah Simmons if
he was just let's say a good player
I think gentlemen in a heartbeat would
take an O lineman but I think they'll
have a lot of they've probably they're
having them now as we speak
there will be a lot of discussion about
Isaiah Simmons at 4:00 because guys like
that don't come along very often at all
so then who's the best pass protector in
the draft in your estimation
I love Derek wills from Alabama Jedrek
wills I think he's really really a
high-level tackle he played right tackle
at Alabama he certainly has the ability
to play left tackle although I think the
delineation between the tackle positions
is no longer meaningful in the NFL a lot
of people still speak as as if it is I
don't see that but I think Jedrek wills
to me is the number one tackle but
there's four tackles who could easily go
in the first round or in the top 15 and
I think they're all worthy of being in
that discussion
Greg Cassell here on the Rich Eisen show
I was talking about it with Daniel
Jeremiah live on at the combine just
watching all of these guys work out and
you know we say it every year they're
bigger stronger faster every year this
year in particular you can get a top 10
player one would think in the bottom
part of of the first round this year
don't you think Greg just the way that
we're talking about needs being filled
at quarterback spots and needs being
filled at just you mentioned how special
a CUDA is how special Simmons is and how
it all works out that you could wind up
with a top 10 player maybe a 20 this
year well what's gonna be interesting in
this draft to me is the wide receivers
there's a lot of good ones right and I
think one of the big storylines in this
draft is how the leaves use big wide
receivers there is a ton a big wide
receivers coming out this year and I'm
sure you remember that from the combine
there's a lot of big guys oh yeah and
they run they ran pretty well I mean you
look at Michael Pittman at 6 for 223 he
ran about a 4 540 again not to put
40-yard dash is to see AC all an end all
but it just gives you a sense of
movement and athleticism and there's a
lot of big wide receivers and I'm very
curious to see how the league views
these players well I mean the the phrase
that we were using
again during our combine coverage on NFL
Network was finding debo that it was
debo Samuel was the guy that everybody
wants to get this year because of how
sizable he is but also how versatile you
could put him in different formations
everywhere and you don't know where he's
coming from I mean Shannon just used him
brilliantly this year who do you think
that debo is in the dress well I think
there's a number of guys who can fill
that role and it's funny because when I
take my notes on receivers and make it a
point to talk about jet sweeps and orbit
reverses and I think there's a lot of
receivers who theoretically fit that hit
I mean Henry rug's who's not as big
right henry rugs comes to mind i mean
he's he's incredibly explosive we knew
that before he ran a four to eight I
think Brandon IU from Arizona State is a
fascinating guy in in terms of the D Bo
Samuel amoled he's about 205 pounds his
wingspan was ridiculous he's not a
completely polished receiver because
he's only played the position for a few
years but you want to get that guy the
ball in space on the move
he players like that I'm bad at picking
where guys get drafted I'm not a good
mock draft guy rich yeah these guys
fascinate me Gregg Cosell here on the
Rich Eisen show what do you think
Belichick is gonna do at his quarterback
position what do you think his plan is
right now
boy you're asking me to get into the
head of Bill Belichick yes I am I mean
just please just just statistically
because the evaluation involves Jared
Stidham the evaluation involves maybe
somebody in this draft Jalen hurts
somebody that might be available rounds
two three four that Belichick thinks I
can grab this guy with Hoyer and Stidham
and create myself a quarterback room
that I can still win this division with
this year in bond I think if you look at
Belichick I think for him and these are
our kool-aid terms but they're true
I think Belichick really loves decision
making and ball placement those are two
of the traits I think that would be near
the top of his list don't forget at his
court he's a defensive coach he does not
want the ball turned over and the NFL
game for a quarterback now with so much
quick game is about ball placement
because it's ball placement that creates
run after catch for
Seavers more than the receiver himself
so if you look in later rounds you know
that's where it's hard to know I mean I
that's we're talking to players comes
into play I mean there's a quarterback
from FIU I don't know if he likes him at
all but James Morgan is a very
interesting laid around prospect the
wild-card here is you don't know what he
thinks of Stidham just like we had no
idea what he thought of brady back right
years ago no doubt he may really like
Jared Stidham and feel like you know
what I can line up with this guy and
he's gonna be a good player well where
was he last year in your evaluation and
where you think that that he might be a
second-year guy cuz again well you know
we only have that one moment against the
Jets where he threw a pick six got
benched Cody Kessler gets signed but he
did just get released yesterday I am
wondering where you think Stidham could
actually reside as a second-year
quarterback yeah I think student was a
guy whose tape was very erratic coming
out of Auburn and a lot of people did
not love their offense you know in the
offense he was asked to run but that's
that's all we could watch talented arm
so I think ultimately you look at a
player that has talent and and the
issues can be worked on and cleaned up
and he threw the ball well and looked
good in training camp last year and in
pre-season whatever that means I made
the point in my notes that he could
develop into a quality starter but there
are many variables for him to reach that
point now he's obviously with a great
coach and a great program so I think
within the context of what they want the
quarterback to do and you can't just say
well they had Tom Brady they have a
certain sense of what they want their
quarterback to do I think that Stidham
could fill that role before I let you go
Greg you know I love talking about your
uncle right correct but that you know I
love talking about you're wrong you can
talk about that all you are your uncle
Howard Gregg Cosell here on the Rich
Eisen show I do this job because of
basically two guys where I wanted to do
it cuz the two guys Marv Albert and and
Howard Cosell
when did you realize your uncle was who
he was
Wow you know what because I grew up we
didn't grow up close to one another
families okay so I didn't see him very
often at all when I was young
so I mean you know that's a hard
question to answer I kind of knew that
let's see I was born in 56 okay
and obviously Howard became big in the
60s he really hit the big time
nationally with Muhammad Ali so I got a
sense of that probably when I was 10 11
or so right and I remember being at camp
I went to kricher Sports Academy horse I
think 13 14 around that age at skills I
remember people starting to talk about
it and that's when I think I really took
note that hey you know my uncle was an
important guy yes again I don't know how
close you were and I just I just loved
obviously though talking about him that
said what do you think he would think
about these days with all of these shows
with everybody offering an opinion where
it's all about opinions and spread
greens and and this person has that
opinion and that person has that opinion
somebody has a column somewhere and as
an opinion in it's all opinion based and
he was one of the first opinionated
people to actually call games and offer
opinions as one would think a character
trait what what do you think you would
think all that Greg again I think he
probably have mixed feelings about it
because the one thing about my uncle as
you know is he was a lawyer he was
number one he was the editor of the Law
Review in his law school so he was an
incredibly smart well-read guy so I
think for the people that really work
hard at it and we all know who works
hard in the business and who doesn't I
think those people need have great
respect and for the others who just
throw out opinions I don't think he'd
have much time for maybe a lot more
diplomatic than your uncle or to put it
how about that I was trying to be
different you know I mean you know I'd
like to still have a job
look I remember reading his books
talking about the jaw khakhra see he did
not think that that players should come
off the field and be opinioni and and
have a microphone in front of them just
because they played you know I remember
being in his first book because I went
to Amherst College where obviously they
don't give athletic scholarships and
played sports they are right here I
remember he used me in as an example of
what ultimately college sports should be
about boy that was a long time ago think
about that
you know I mean I'll never forget I met
him once cuz you know he was tight with
Steinbrenner right oh okay I met him
once in the press box at Yankee Stadium
and you know I went up to him and I just
said hello to him and what he you know
meant to me and he was he was nice and
then at one point he looked at my press
credentials goes at what erstwhile
publication do you work for and then he
goes the Staten Island Advance come on
like that and it was just he just what
erstwhile publication do you work for is
what he said I'll never forget it
speak to Howard Katz he has a great
salary as well about the first time he
been my uncle yeah I was starting out in
the business well I mean he goes way
back to the Roone Arledge ABC sports
days now the president of NFL Films
where where you you obviously know what
it's all about Greg I appreciate the
call truly do if you don't mind I'm
gonna keep calling you before the draft
I really enjoy the chats it's been way
too long I greatly appreciate the time
rich anytime thank you my friend I
appreciate it I'll look for my call will
be happening again that's Greg Cosell at
Greg Cosell on Twitter I follow him you
should as well